[Aplausos]
amigos las islas malvinas son uno de los
territorios más inhóspitos remotos y
aislados del planeta situados a unos 400
kilómetros de la patagonia argentina las
malvinas están formadas por más de 700
islas que tienen una superficie de
aproximadamente 12.000 kilómetros
cuadrados algo más que puerto rico
chipre o el líbano
[Música]
sin embargo a pesar de ello sabéis qué
población tienen en estas islas pues
apenas 3.400 personas es decir en este
archipiélago la densidad de población
viene a ser de un habitante por cada
cuatro kilómetros cuadrados queridos
amigos de visual político esto hace que
las malvinas formen junto a groenlandia
y el archipiélago ártico de svalbard el
pódium de los territorios autónomos más
deshabitados del planeta
dicho de otro modo hablamos de unas
islas donde es mucho más fácil
encontrarse con pingüinos que con
personas para que os hagáis una idea tan
solo un estadio de fútbol como el
santiago bernabéu tiene un aforo que es
23 23 veces más grande que toda la
población de las islas malvinas pero
cuidado no solo es que estén casi
deshabitadas es que además como ya
sabéis mantienen una enorme disputa con
argentina quien les reclama como
territorio propio y como argentina es el
país más cercano eso hace que la
práctica estas islas estén muy pero que
muy aisladas
[Música]
y es aquí donde nos surgen unas cuantas
preguntas de quién y andrés viven las
malvinas por qué son tan polémicas puede
acaso un territorio tan pequeñito
sobrevivir ser sostenible amigos sabréis
contestar a estas preguntas y qué pasa
si os digo que las malvinas pueden
convertirse en uno de los territorios
más ricos del mundo no me creéis atentos
[Música]
de qué viven las malvinas
amigos os hago una pregunta sabréis
decirme cuál es el territorio autónomo
más rico de américa latina' puede que
muchos estéis pensando en puerto rico-
chile o panamá verdad pues no nada de
eso con un producto interior bruto de
más de 60 mil dólares per cápita el
territorio más rico de toda
latinoamérica son las malvinas ojo
hablamos de casi 5 veces el pib per
cápita de argentina
[Música]
sí sí ya sé que las malvinas no son un
país pero tienen sus propias
instituciones de gobierno y muchísimas
competencias en la práctica son casi
como un país y su economía va viento en
popa ya toda vela
[Música]
a pesar de estar aisladas y
prácticamente deshabitadas durante la
última década la economía local ha
promediado un crecimiento económico de
más del 5% anual en términos reales y no
sólo eso a diferencia del resto de
gobiernos latinoamericanos bueno y de
casi todos los gobiernos del mundo las
autoridades locales no sólo no tienen
deudas sino que acumulan unas reservas
algo así como un fondo soberano de más
de 250 millones de dólares
ojo porque 250 millones de dólares nos
puede parecer poco dinero pero si
tenemos en cuenta su escasa población
hablamos de que los ahorros del gobierno
superan los 75 mil dólares por cada
habitante de las islas pero vale vale
todo esto está muy bien pero regresemos
a la pregunta con la que empezamos de
qué diantres viven en estas islas puede
que aquí muchos tengáis la tentación de
pensada así como vamos a ver enrique que
nos estás contando las malvinas son un
territorio de reino unido- seguro seguro
que están subvencionadas hasta las
trancas y que el sector público es la
actividad más importante verdad pues
amigos lo cierto es que no nada de eso
[Música]
[Aplausos]
no tenemos ninguna duda acerca de
nuestra soberanía que ha sido continua
desde 1833
margaret thatcher las malvinas son un
territorio autosuficiente y reino unido-
tan solo se hace cargo de los costes de
defensa nada más y estos costes ni son
tan grandes ni serían necesarios si no
fuera por el conflicto político
existente
[Música]
veréis lo cierto amigos es que las
malvinas eran unas islas relativamente
pobres que probablemente estaban
condenadas a despoblarse pero en 1987
todo cambio los habitantes de la isla se
dieron cuenta de que tenían que
prosperar y aprendieron a hacer negocios
y amigos en esto de hacer negocios los
británicos son todos unos campeones su
forma de vida es británica su lealtad es
a la corona son pocos en número pero
tienen el derecho de vivir en paz de
elegir su propia forma de vida y de
determinar su propia lealtad es el deseo
del pueblo británico y el deber del
gobierno de su majestad hacer todo lo
posible para defender ese derecho esa
será nuestra esperanza y nuestro
esfuerzo margaret thatcher
y el caso es que en 1987 el gobierno de
las malvinas comenzó a vender licencias
a empresas pesqueras extranjeras para
que operaran dentro de sus zonas de
pesca de su territorio marítimo es decir
comenzaron a tratar sus aguas como si de
cualquier otro recurso se tratara
gracias a esta medida del gobierno
recauda un montón de dinero cada año y
también se preocupa mucho de la
sostenibilidad de la pesca para que no
se termine la fuente de ingresos
pero aquí no termina todo ni muchísimo
menos desde esa época el gobierno de las
malvinas ha tenido tres cosas muy pero
que muy claras primero que hay que
alentar la creación de empresas los
habitantes de las malvinas que se
conocen todos tienen que vivir de lo que
produzca su trabajo no de los impuestos
y el gasto público segundo para que esto
sea posible los impuestos tienen que ser
moderados y de hecho los son fijados en
las malvinas no existe el impuesto a las
compras los impuestos especiales son muy
reducidos la gasolina es más barata que
en el reino unido- y una persona que
digamos gane 2 mil 500 dólares al mes
pagarán impuestos un total de 140
dólares mensuales es decir apenas un 5,6
por ciento
y tercero el gobierno local no solo no
tiene que endeudarse sino que tiene que
ahorrar deuda no queremos deuda como
podéis ver en este gráfico aquí los
superávits son casi una obligación
[Música]
de esta forma los habitantes de las
malvinas no sólo no tienen que pagar
intereses de la deuda pública sino que
cada año obtienen un montón de
beneficios por los ahorros del fondo
soberano y además cuando lo necesitan
tienen capacidad para invertir que es lo
que ahora están haciendo lanzándose a
construir un nuevo puerto una ampliación
del aeropuerto etcétera etcétera
[Música]
pues bien gracias a todo esto de las
malvinas no hay paro y el 90% de las
personas en edad de trabajar tienen un
empleo en los últimos años sectores como
el turismo el de las piscifactorías se
han disparado las cosas van tan bien que
los planes del gobierno pasan por que
los próximos años la población de las
islas prácticamente se duplique con la
llegada de trabajadores extranjeros la
parte mala es que como están tan
aislados y son tan pocos pues aquí
amazon no llega internet es más lento
que una tortuga con reuma y desde luego
es algo que os guste la naturaleza a
pasarlo bien puede llegar a ser una
tarea complicada pero amigos esto no es
nada con lo que puede estar por venir
atentos
[Música]
camino a la riqueza
vale creo que no hay dudas de que los
habitantes de las malvinas han sabido
hacer las cosas bien lo que nos dice que
incluso en un territorio tan pequeño y
tan aislado se puede tener éxito cuando
las cosas se hacen con cabeza y no es
difícil porque no hace falta inventar
nada con hacer todo lo contrario a esto
es más que suficiente la expropiación de
la empresa sidetur pero amigos a pesar
de que las cosas ya están tan bien por
estos lares la suerte de los habitantes
de las malvinas está a punto de dar un
nuevo salto a la estratosfera fijaos
[Música]
en 1993 el centro geológico británico
localizó petróleo bajo las aguas que
rodean las malvinas petróleo explotable
tras años de intensos trabajos ahora el
resultado puede empezar a dar sus frutos
[Música]
dos pequeñas petroleras británicas
rockhopper exploration y la premier oil
están a punto de empezar a construir la
infraestructura que permitirá que en
apenas tres años la producción petrolera
de las malvinas supere los 80 mil
barriles diarios tan solo necesitan que
el precio del petróleo se mantenga por
encima de los 45 dólares por barril para
que el negocio sea rentable
[Música]
si vale 80 mil barriles puede parecer
poco pero no olvidéis que estamos
hablando de las malvinas 80.000 barriles
al precio actual de unos 60 dólares por
barril suponen un ingreso anual de 1.800
millones de dólares el 9 por ciento de
todos estos ingresos y el 26 por ciento
de los beneficios finales que obtengan
las petroleras irán a manos del gobierno
local hablamos de una cifra que
probablemente superará los 200 200
millones de dólares es decir tan solo en
ingresos públicos cerca de 60 mil
dólares adicionales por habitante y año
y por supuesto luego estarían los
empleos los salarios y los impuestos que
toda esta nueva actividad toda esta
nueva industria va a generar
y ojo tan solo estamos hablando del
comienzo porque en estos momentos hay
más zonas que están siendo exploradas si
las cosas marchan bien en 10 años la
producción diaria de las malvinas podría
superar ampliamente los 100 mil barriles
cada día en total se calcula que las
reservas explotables de petróleo de este
archipiélago podrían superar los 1000
millones de barriles
[Aplausos]
amigo si se cumplen los plazos en apenas
unos años las máquinas podrían
convertirse en uno de los lugares más
ricos de todo el planeta puedo asegurar
que una cosa nunca cambiará nuestro
compromiso absoluto con el pueblo y la
soberanía de las islas malvinas
hoy las malvinas nos pueden parecer un
lugar inhóspito pero con trabajo buenos
salarios impuestos bajos mejores
comunicaciones un estado de derecho
sólido poca corrupción muchas libertades
civiles y mucha seguridad a lo mejor
cambia nuestra impresión sobre la vida
en estas islas nos parece sobre todo si
desgraciadamente la comparamos con la
vida en otros países del continente
amigos esta es la realidad a la que se
enfrentan las malvinas desde luego más
allá de la soberanía si se cumplen las
previsiones estas islas podrían ser todo
un negocio para las regiones del sur de
argentina tal vez haya llegado la hora
de aparcar viejas disputas y buscar un
beneficio para todos no os parece
cuando me reuní con el presidente macri
a principios de este mes convirtiéndome
en el primer primer ministro británico
en visitar a buenos aires fue un placer
concentrarme no sólo en lo que nos
separa sino sobre todo en lo que podemos
lograr juntos
theresa may si os ha resultado
interesante el vídeo darle a like y no
olvidéis suscribiros a visual político
pensar de un momento en que otro canal
podrías encontrar vídeos sobre la
economía de un lugar que apenas tiene
3.400 habitantes un saludo y hasta la
próxima
[Música]
[Aplausos]